[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce débat élections
législatives qui concerne la 9e
circonscription des yvelines débat entre
bruno milian bonjour vous êtes député
sortant candidat ensemble mode âme dans
cette circonscription pardon et laurent
maurin bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
candidat est ré venez vous êtes le
premier est reine qualifier au deuxième
tour dans ce département 1 alors on va
parler évidemment un certain nombre de
problèmes je présentais très brièvement
la cette 9e circonscription qui suit eu
à l'ouest des yvelines qui comprend 4
comptant le canton d'aubergenville le
canto de bonnières sur seine suit de
guerville et celui de goût d'eau c'est
une circonscription plutôt rurale mais
il ya une grande ville qui est numéro et
puis elle est aussi la ville
d'aubergenville historiquement c'est une
circonscription qui a été tenu longtemps
par la droite il va débuter assez connus
qui est théorique uc et puis
vous a été élu bruno milliers en 2017 et
vous demander aux électeurs de vous
refaire confiance on va regarder des
résultats du premier tour alors brute
2002 est en tête avec 26 34% des voix
soit 11 1275 voix vous êtes je suis par
laurent morin avec 22,45 % des voix ne
fut ni 613 voix vous étiez talonner
d'ailleurs par le candidat de l'ani
baisse ça s'est joué à très peu de vous
avez 22 45 il avait 22 25 % des voix il
ya deux candidats s'avère très forts
scores aux mureaux mais au bureau on a
noté beaucoup d'abstention 70% je crois
d'abstention alors on va commencer
peut-être par cette question je vais
commencer avec vous puisque le tirage au
sort en a décidé ainsi bruno médiane
avec sept abstentions
comment comment vous les expliquer
justement elle est plus forte à dire que
dans cette circonscription que dans le
reste des yvelines puisqu'elle a peu
plus de 52% comment vous expliquez cette
abstention alors qu'est une offre
politique est quand même très forte
c'est toujours le même débat de toute
façon on voit bien que sur cette
circonscription là c'est en général
circonscription l'abstention est la plus
forte sur les scrutins et là ça glisse
ça glisse de plus en plus c'est une
progression lente mais certaine donc il
ya effectivement il va falloir changer
des habitudes politiques de manière
assez drastiques c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous savez bien j'ai j'ai monté
ainsi huit ans que j'ai mis entre
parenthèses pendant les élections
présidentielle et législatives pour
essayer de reconnecter les citoyens avec
avec la chose publique je ne parle pas
de politique je parle de choses
publiques avec des débats qui s'instaure
entre des grands témoins sur un thème
particulier et des citoyens moi n'étant
là que comme loyal on va dire m le
maître de cérémonie et pouvoir répondre
aux questions logistiques que se posent
les citoyens et sur lui sur ce qu'on a
fait notamment le dernier qui était
assez intéressant sur agriculture et
ruralité agriculture pardon et
transition écologique et bien on a pu
s'apercevoir que des positions qui
étaient diamétralement opposées ont pu
enfin communiquer ensemble et
s'apercevoir que c'était pas aussi
simple qu'on pouvait le décrire
notamment dans les médias ou simplement
dans la pensée qu'on a comme une de ces
choses là et je pense qu'il faut aussi
arriver à faire ça redonner cette ce
pouvoir de discussion et pour moi c'est
important parce que ça me permettait
aussi de pouvoir remonter des points du
coup dans les différents ministères de
choses qu'on est pas forcément vu partir
de ce que vous est désormais absolument
monter leur mort assurent sur cette
abstention forte que vous regrettez je
suppose aussi v
comme vous et quand vous expliquer qu
est ce qui fait qu faut des gens se
disent ouais on se reconnaît pas dans
une offre politique qui quand même
assez impressionnante dans toutes les
circonscriptions oui c'est vrai que
l'offre politique est importante un sur
l'ensemble des circonscriptions de
france et en particulier la 9e
circonscription puisqu'il y avait dans
cette circonscription 14 candidats le
plus grand nombre de candidats dans le
département des yvelines je crois qu'il
ya deux phénomènes qui explique ce
phénomène de l'abstention d'abord le
fait que les électeurs pensent peut-être
que en ayant voté à l'élection
présidentielle il n'y a peut-être plus
dangereux ou moins d'enjeux aux
élections législatives alors que
véritablement il ya un enjeu très
important celui de dawn de donner ou pas
une majorité absolue au président de la
république et en l'occurrence de lui
donner ou pas les pleins pouvoirs donc
évidemment c'est un enjeu important et
puis le deuxième phénomène peut-être
c'est le fait que de plus en plus
d'électeurs ne se retrouvent plus ne
sont plus représentés à l'assemblée
nationale et ceci est dû au fait que la
proportionnelle n'est pas
mise en place de manière totale ou
partielle et là je terminerai sur lequel
vous serez d'accord
d'accord sur le contrat sauf que sauf
que vous me permettrez de dire que le
président de la république emmanuel
macron avait effectivement au début de
son précédent quinquennat émile à la
promesse d'instaurer une dose de
proportionnelle et malheureusement il
n'a pas pu il n'a pas su il n'a pas
voulu le faire surtout c'est ça c'est
une chose que des gens je pense que
senna qui s'est opposée mais si vous
savez très bien avec yotaro fonctionnel
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord puisque
le modem défense a depuis sa création
donc il n'ya pas de soucis moi en tout
cas en tout cas c'est un c'est un échec
c'est une promesse non tenue eh bien il
sera payé sur ce cas qu on verra on
verra ça mais on l'espère en tout cas
moi je l'espère fortement
ouvert il ya peut-être pas beaucoup de
poids sur lesquels vous êtes d'accord
déçu leurs est-ce que je vais je vous
pouvez tous les deux de répondre vous
êtes vous avez parlé du think tank que
vous aviez créé est-ce que ça danger au
fond pour la démocratie cette abstention
parce qu'on assure l'impression que
démocratie c'est un système qui est
toujours existé qu'il existera toujours
est-ce que c'est pas un système fragile
on s'est arrangé pour la démocratie pour
rebondir sur ce que disait laurent morin
pour le coup je suis d'accord avec lui
pourquoi cette proportionnelle à
l'assemblée nationale parce qu' il vaut
mieux combattre les oppositions à
l'intérieur de l'hémicycle de la chambre
des représentants du peuple que les
combattent dehors dans la rue donc tout
ce qu'on pourra créer même le think tank
etc oui ça re connecte les gens mais la
première des choses à faire
effectivement c'est qu'on instaure à je
ne sais pas sous quelle forme il faudra
voir moi je suis plutôt pour la
proportionnelle intégrale à titre
personnel parce que je pense
qu'effectivement la voie de la voix des
citoyens doit être présenté à
l'assemblée nationale et sa force de
toute façon la proportionnelle sur des
sujets importants sur des lois
importantes à des coalitions à
l'intérieur de l'assemblée nationale
donc ça fait un règlement fort qui donne
un gouvernement fort qui lui même donne
un président fort au contraire
l'exécutif pense toujours qu'il va être
affaiblie par la proportionnelle moi je
pense que c'est une erreur or noir oui
effectivement c'est ce que c'est ce que
je viens de le dire c'est à dire que la
proportionnelle si elle n'est pas mise
en place effectivement les débats de
société se font dans la rue et ça a été
le cas d'ailleurs sous le quinquennat
précédent notamment avec la crise des
gilet jaune sur laquelle je reviendrai
au moment où nous aborderons le sujet du
pouvoir d'achat et donc lorsque les
débats se font dans la rue ils ont
tendance à devenir violent et a provoqué
du chaos donc oui bien sûr il faut
mettre en place la proportionnelle et si
possible intégral mais je regrette
encore une fois je le jeu je le redis
que malheureusement du côté de la
majorité présidée majorité
présidentielle pardon il ya beaucoup
d'effets d'annoncé mais peu d'actes en
vérité sur ces sujets démocratiques
musulmans va pas réécrire l'histoire je
voudrais expliquer exactement ce qui
s'est passé vous le savez très bien donc
un tout petit peu d'honnêteté
intellectuelle c'était un paquet
constitutionnel qui devait être votée
par l'assemblée nationale qui a été
empêché parce que le sénat ne voulait
pas alors dans ce cas là pas de
promesses mais il aurait fallu non non
c'est pas une question veut pas de
promesses on n'a jamais eu l'occasion de
leur faire les quelques crises on va le
faire dans son quinquennat parce qu'il y
va de la démocratie et vous pouvez
compter sur les forces du modem qui
seront présentes à l'assemblée
pour pousser ça le plus forte aussi
permettez moi d'en douter a pas pour le
modèle non alors on va parler de ce qui
s'est passé au premier tour bruno
mullier de vous êtes en tête dans 50
villes ou villages de sur 81 2
387 pendant et laurent morin dans 32
quel est le ski est ce qui est important
et je le dis vous êtes le premier
candidat est raide qualifier au deuxième
tour quel est le message comment vous
est le message que vous avez compris des
électeurs je pense qu'il ya un message
de mécontentement vis-à-vis de la
politique était mené par le gouvernement
on l'a ressenti aussi à à l'élection
présidentielle finalement si vous
regardez bien circonscription c'est
c'est vraiment elle requiert ans de télé
c'est vraiment une petite france puisque
même pour le résultat des élections
législatives on aa je crois 1% près
exactement le même résultat que ce qu'on
a eu au niveau au niveau national pour
le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle voilà là dessus il faut
travailler il va falloir que pendant ce
débat on dise quand même un certain
nombre de vérités pour que les gens
choisis sont toutes en toute quiétude et
en toute conscience mais finalement
c'est le reflet exact de ce qui s'est
passé au plan national
oui quel est le message que vous
traversez le reflet de ce qui s'est
passé au niveau national c'est à dire
que la majorité présidentielle régresse
puisqu'elle perd niveau national et y
compris dans la 9e circonscription elle
perd énormément de points 6 points au
niveau national monsieur millièmes passe
de 37 % en 2017 à 26% en 2022 las nubes
elle régresse aussi l air disparaît le
ps gosse les composantes de la nuque
baisse en 2000 en 2010 est réalisé un
score de rapport à la gauche parce
que maintenant il réside il réalise 23 %
donc ils sont en régression
contrairement à ce que les médias
essayent de nous faire croire sur une
dynamique autour de jean luc mélenchon
ça n'est pas vrai et puis l'événement
important je crois dans les yvelines
c'est la disparition de la droite il n'y
a plus aucun représentant de la droite
au second tour il flanche complètement
ils perdent 7 point au niveau national
et deux députés sortants élèves rejeter
le deal sont pas qualifiés aux délégués
exactement et puis des scores même très
très très faible de certains de leurs
représentants par exemple sur la 8e
circonscription michel vialay qui fait
moins de 8% donc et et nous concernant
donc tous les partis sont en régression
est donc le seul parti en dynamique
c'est bien le rassemblement national
puisque au niveau national nous
augmentons nos scores et dans cette
circonscription nous augmentons très
fortement nos scores puisque nous
passons de 15 à 22% de 6500 électeurs à
9613 électeurs je réalise même un score
plus important que jean marie thé tard
en 2017 alors qu'il était maire de
houdan le mérite et arrêtaient de
députés
de droite républicaine qui vous a
précédé et que vous avez battu en 2010
cette voie que je précise à un tout tout
à fait et donc effectivement on voit que
la dynamique nationale du rassemblement
national s'est appliqué dans la 9e
circonscription et même un peu plus
puisque je réalise un score un peu plus
important que celui de marine le pen au
premier tour et je crois que ça que cela
s'explique par une implantation depuis
plusieurs années dans cette
circonscription j'habite la
circonscription je me suis présenté aux
élections départementale sur le canton
de beaune hier j'ai été élu au sein de
la communauté urbaine gps au dont une
partie des communes est présente sur la
9e circonscription donc je crois que
l'implantation plus la dynamique
nationale explique le score important
que nous avons réalisés dans la 9e
circonscription vouliez moi j'ai une
interrogation quand même le roman
excusez moi de
de voir cette interrogation mais si
votre implantation locale et si vraiment
votre progression était si forte que ça
pourquoi n'avez vous n'avez vous pas
conservé même la ville oui alors là on
parle on parle d'un autre sujet à part
d'une élection municipale
on parle de désactiver si vous avez une
gestion exemplaire de la ville de mantes
la ville vous auriez garder cette ville
vous la jouer cool dans le maire était
cyril août non mais les circonstances et
d'ailleurs les situations auxquelles
vous vous êtes vous vous allez succomber
compte par rapport à des as des as des
candidats aux élections municipales un
candidat de droite notamment aux
élections municipales vous êtes vous est
permis d'intervenir dans cette élection
je trouve justement il s'est quand même
le mans ça vous et moi députés l'avaient
chassée inscriptions chaque citoyen doit
s'exprimer oui enfin je trouve que
c'était particulièrement indécent de la
part d'un député d'une autre
circonscription d'intervenir dans cette
élection je ne rentrerai pas dans la
direction d'un hôte ne mente habile
entre la ville je ne rentrerais
d'ailleurs pas dans les détails des
circonstances de cette élection il ya eu
un certain nombre d'irrégularités très
forte et finalement effectivement nous
perdons mais de manière honorable avec
44% je pense que d'ailleurs quand on est
sur le terrain entre la ville on se rend
compte aujourd'hui qu'il y à beaucoup
demandent lillois qui regrette en fait
d'avoir voté pour nos adversaires de
l'époque et qui est en regrette qu'on ne
soit pas prise ni si pas le suivre je
vous essayez municipal de nantes la
ville ce soir là lui québec et de la
8ème à sur la vie chère vite dans la
neige les habite et où sont vos
discussions ça ne vous regarde pas oui
parce que montmagny vous habitiez passe
ouest et bien je vous avez de très
mauvaises informations de tout jeu moi
j'avais eu deux jumeaux bidens ou le
passé c'est justement le petit village
il y avait alors il faut un point sur
les chronos pour que nos médias nous
avaient utilisé un peu moins de quatre
minutes et et laurent mauras zanatta un
peu plus de cinq minutes pour l'instant
mais c'est est ce que vous abordez une
question qui est intéressante vous avez
fait un
alors scellé chez les partisans des
macros nist on ne sait pas très bien
s'il faut si certains s'y renom dans le
cadre ou un duel d'autres la du ps et 1
et rennes certains choisissent les as
d'autres les autres d'autres ne se
prononcent pas vous êtes vous avez été
très clair là dessus vous avez dit si
j'avais le choix entre rn1 épaisse je
voterai plus tôt du ps parce que le
combat contre l'extrême droite a été
toujours un combat de ma vie en gros
c'est ça oui c'est d'abord ça a été
toujours le cool ça a été le combat de
ma vie parce que moi j'ai eu la chance
d'être élevé à l'étranger donc de
m'ouvrir à d'autres cultures et que ce
relent même si vous avez ripoliné la
façade mais ce relent xénophobe
surolan xénophobe que vous avez toujours
dans votre programme
les arguments le messie mais ce jour là
d'autant plus que vous je ne connaissais
très mal donc je le sais pas j'aurai
plus de temps dont vous connaissez très
mal et quand vous parlez d'ouverture
d'esprit si vous connaissiez mon
parcours vous parlez je ne viendrai vous
en avais pas je parle de votre du
programme du rassemblement national je
mets pas en cause vous voilà que ne
prenez pas tout non plus pour vous
menacer parle de votre cas personnel
donc je comparais au mien vous parlez
moi j'ai dit voilà étiez partis vivre à
l'étranger travailler à l'étranger ce
qui est légalement vous j'ai passé mon
enfance là bas j'ai pas trouvé également
été mon cas donc passé quand même 18 ans
à l'étranger donc de plus loin je me
souvienne j'ai combattu l'extrême droite
toujours
nu baisse ça dépend des candidats moi
j'oublie pas comme dans cet attelage
baroque oui il ya le vaudou il ya quand
même des socialistes des communistes et
écologistes et moi mon sentiment tel que
je livre à chaque fois qu'on pose la
question c'est que je pense au co - pour
les socialistes puisque je pense qu'ils
ont un groupe à l'assemblée nationale
cet attelage va s'arrêter assez vite
c'est à dire que dès que tout le monde
sera mis en place et bien us va exploser
parce que il ya trop de différences
programmatiques entre la france
insoumise et les socialistes peuvent pas
rester comme ça parce que d'abord il ya
encore beaucoup de gens de gauche et
beaucoup de sociaux-démocrates qui
existe et si le parti socialiste veut
mourir mais il a qu'à suivre comme un
seul homme jean luc mélenchon et le
parti socialiste mort a donc je pense
que cette alliance qui est une alliance
de circonstance uniquement pour les
élections sont bien réussi leur coup
parce que quand on regarde les sondages
ils vont arriver
quand même avec une livraison tel nombre
d'arrivants augmenté le nombre de leurs
députés n'est qu'une n'est qu'une
alliance de circonstance c'est pour cela
que d'un côté j'ai effectivement le
ratio national qui le méritent au moins
de ne pas se cacher derrière son petit
doigt et qui reste rassemblement
national d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas fait
d'accord avec reconquête j'ai dû
concéder d'accord et de l'autre côté cet
attelage et dans cet attelage il ya des
gens avec qui j'ai déjà travaillé avec
qui je serai en capacité de retravailler
avec vous ça sera plus compliqué
leur embarras reds ont relevé une
déclaration vous avez fait parce que
auprès des impressions quand même que
vous tout le monde recherche un peu les
voit de belles voix qui aiguise les voix
du ps vous avez dit d'ailleurs vous en
appeler aux électeurs de l'aufo qui ont
voté pour le candidat de gauche au
premier tour on disait que j'appelle les
électeurs de gauche être libres de leur
choix
voilà je fais également à l'appel aux
abstentionnistes et aux électeurs le
patriote
vous espérez que d'un certain nombre de
gens qui sont prononcés pour le candidat
du pit reproduisons ce se tourne vers
vous écoutez si l'on regarde les études
qui sont sortis au lendemain du second
tour de l'élection présidentielle
on constate que seuls 38 % des électeurs
de jean luc mélenchon ont voté emmanuel
macron c'est à dire qu'il ya 62 %
majorité des électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon qui n'ont pas voté pour
le président sortant soit ils se sont
abstenus soit ils ont voté marine le pen
et à 18% pour marine le pen et le reste
vous que la france où
je vais vous dire ce que je veux vous
dire c'est que le front républicain
auquel vous vous référez 716 c'est
terminé
s'est laissé prendre à ma solitude mais
non c'est pas une question de front
républicain alger expliqué très bien il
n'y a pas de front républicain il ya
quelques mois le rassemblement national
pour moi qui n'est pas démocratique et
dans la nuque mais c'est des gens qui
sont des sociaux démocrates avec
eichmann écrit que vous aviez une salle
debout dit mme ofran le front
républicain ça marche plus le front
républicain ne marche plus et je pense
qu'effectivement pour revenir à la
circonscription qui nous intéresse je
pense qu'il y a sans doute une majorité
d'électeurs de candidats reprennent
représentant jean luc mélenchon qui ne
voteront pas pour monsieur 1000 yens
tout simplement parce qu'ils vont
s'attacher aux idées et pas aux effets
d'annoncé pas aux postures politiques et
les idées quelles sont elles et bien
scellé ce sont les idées de la macro ni
c'est à dire une déconstruction sociale
un saccage du système social et je pense
que les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
ne veulent pas cela ne veulent pas une
retraite à 65 ans ne veulent pas la
déconstruction de nos systèmes social
pour lequel les français se sont battus
depuis très longtemps et je pense qu'ils
reproduiront sans doute la proportion
approximativement que je vous ai cité la
proportion qui a été là celle de
l'élection présidentielle et je pense
d'ailleurs j'en ai rencontrés sur le
terrain un certain nombre de militants
de victor payack qui me disait
effectivement le rejet qui était le gobe
l'autorisé la candidate de jean luc
mélenchon 2 de nouvelles c'est qu'ils me
disaient leur rejet de manière générale
et sanaa ça n'a rien à voir avec les
personnes bien sûr mais le rejet de la
politique incarnée par monsieur macron
par monsieur 1000 yens et il est tout à
fait probable que une grande partie de
cet électorat se retrouvent sur ma
candidature est ce que vous plaidez pose
qu'on appelle parfois une alliance des
populistes ou faux
les parce qu'on dit parfois que la
gauche mais le c17 et populiste et que
la droite c'est à dire ce que je pense
qu'il y a une division artificielle
effectivement du peuple et
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes face à un
gouvernement et un pouvoir oligarchique
qui concentre l'ensemble des pouvoirs
les pouvoirs technologiques les pouvoirs
médiatiques les pouvoirs politiques les
pouvoirs financiers et que face à ça si
le peuple reste divisée il sera écrasée
comme il l'a été les cinq dernières
années il le sera encore plus dans les
cinq prochaines années d'ailleurs la
majorité présidentielle a d'ores et déjà
dit que dès cet été ils mettront en
place des réformes radicales et profonde
donc c'est pour ça que moi
personnellement je pense que la majorité
présidentielle peut être défini comme
l'extrême centre et moi j'appelle à tous
les électeurs quel qu'il soit à faire
barrage à cette extrême à cet extrême là
à l'extrémisme de monsieur ma chronique
parce que c'est les deux minutes de
retard donc vous avez un peu de temps
pour répondre à d'autres provinces on
avait bien compris au moins vous a un
point commun avec l'arène est pleine
après on va parler des trois thèmes
paris a beaucoup lui en parler parce que
moi aussi j'ai rencontré des électeurs
de victor baia qui utilise exactement là
vers de ce que dit monsieur laurent
morin mais ça ça prouve bien que les
avis sont partagés là dessus peut-être
que ce que vous allez rencontrer été un
petit peu plus radicaux que ceux que
j'ai rencontrés c'est pour ça que je
pense que les sociaux démocrates où
seront faire les choses la part des
choses et puis on verra bien de toute
façon personne n'est comptable des
électeurs de personnes donc voilà la
seule chose qu'on peut faire c'est de
convaincre les gens entre un programme
qui est réaliste économiquement réaliste
économiquement intenable si on parle
d'économie et puis un programme qu'il
est un petit peu moins mais ça je
suppose qu'on va entrer dans la
discussion plus avant là dessus alors on
peut aborder le thème des thèmes qui
équipe qui est très important c'est
celui du pouvoir d'achat
surtout dans une circonscription rurale
je le disais donc où il ya sans doute un
problème fort qui se pose de ce quad
vous voulez commencer pour une mignonne
là dessus je suis vous voulez moi je
joue simplement dire une chose c'est que
je pense pas qu'on ait attendu la fin du
quinquennat pour parler pouvoir d'achat
il ya quand même des choses qui ont été
faites que les gens ont peut-être un
petit peu oublié entre la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation les prix macron
l'augmentation du minimum vs de
l'allocation adultes handicapés qui ne
s'était pas fait depuis au moins 20 ans
donc on est comptable on live avec une
situation donnée on met comptable de
cette situation là quand même amélioré
puis à des gens qu'on oublie une chose
c'est la suppression des cotisations
salariales j'ai pas si vous venez ça
c'est tombé en 2018 et ça a quand même
fait vous allez me dire c'est pas
beaucoup mais en pourcentage par rapport
à un smic ça représente quand même
quelques jeux s'est fait 17 euros net
par mois en plus pour quelqu'un qui est
au smic à l'époque on n'était pas bons
on était dans aucune crise donc c'était
vraiment et c'était vraiment de
l'augmentation de pouvoir d'achat que
donnait le gouvernement à tous les
citoyens hors période de crise lortal de
crise et il a tout ça mais on en a bien
on a fait bien d'autres où ça fait des
avancées sociales on en a fait il y en a
une qui me revient en mémoire parce que
je pense un petit peu aux femmes dans
ces cas là c'est notamment le fait que
maintenant une femme divorcée dont le
mari est un délicat ils ne payent pas
les pensions alimentaires s'adresse
directement à la caf et reçoit sa
pension alimentaire et c'est l'état qui
se retourne vers le mari toutes ces
petites choses rares évidemment nous
c'est pas des slogans on dit pas on va
faire le smic à temps on dit pas on fait
la retraite à 60 ans on en reparlera
peut-être mais la retraite à 60 ans sans
savoir comment ni comment enfin j'ai
compris moi si j'ai pas tout compris
mais j'ai compris que c'était à 60 ans à
condition de commencer à travailler
avant 20 ans a beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent à ce qu'un problème c'est
peut-être parler il y en a oui mais bien
quand même un peu moins et puis surtout
aussi cette histoire de supprimer
l'impôt sur le revenu pour les jeunes de
moins de 30 ans si vous êtes un start
hopper ou un joueur de foot qui viennent
des millions à 29 et 30 ans vous allez
vous n'allez pas payer un pays alors que
l'ouvrier à 31 ans lui il va payer plein
pot donc il ya quand même il ya quand
même dans ce que vous mais dans ce que
vous mettez et puisqu'on est sur le
pouvoir d'achat je peux revenir un tout
petit peu sur l'histoire de la tva passe
la tva c'est bien beau mais vous le
savez en plus c'est ça qui est terrible
c'est en cela que vos propositions
patrice carmouze le disais tout à
l'heure sont qualifiés un petit peu de
populiste vite que vous avez beau être
baisser la tva vous allez mettre la tva
à zéro sur les produits de première
nécessité mais la baisse de tva n'a
jamais profité aux citoyens d'abord
c'est injuste parce que vous mettez à
zéro pour tout le monde donc c'est pas
ciblé jeudi devait le gars qui roulent
en ferrari n'a pas besoin qu'on lui
mette à tva à zéro celui qui a besoin de
pouvoir d'achat c'est celui qui est au
smic donc c'est injuste et ça n'a jamais
profiter réellement aux citoyens je
prends le dernier exemple en date c'est
pas compliqué la tva qu'on a baissé pour
les restaurateurs
14,1 pour cent de moins bénéfice pour le
consommateur 1 9%
que prennent les halles est passé de 5 5
à 0 pour l'alimentation par exemple pour
les produits de première nécessité ils
vont gagner 5 5 de pouvoir d'achat c'est
factuellement faux en plus cette mesure
là je ne sais pas où vous récupérez la
voie aux flambeaux 110 milliards ça
coûte votre programme par 110 milliards
le programme effectivement dans lesquels
il y a ces mesures qui ont été proposées
par marine le pen pendant l'élection
présidentielle et que nous porterons à
l'assemblée nationale par
l'intermédiaire de notre groupe que nous
allons je pense réussir a construit qui
n'ont constitué de manière puissante ce
sont des propositions bruno myle yen n'a
sans doute pas étudié précisément le
projet de marine le pen mais ce sont des
propositions qui sont pros qui sont qui
sont chiffrés qui sont chiffrés et qui
sont financés
tous les économistes est ce que ce ne
l'est pas oui enfin vos économistes non
mais n'en ai pas pu m c'est pas de
leçons s'il vous plaît aidez moi je
m'amuse et je lui ai dit tu es sûr je me
suis expert sur les experts auxquels
vous faites référence parce que ses
experts et notamment un certain nombre
qui font partie de ceux qui qui vous
conseillent nous ont amenés aujourd'hui
dans ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
large dans le mur la dette a explosé on
est hantée en vous est en déficit public
déficit commercial de les services
publics s'effondre l'hôpital s'effondre
la santé f1 ou comment vous fait envie
de location salle et la sécurité c'est
fonde donc s'il vous plaît pas de leçons
mais sur deux on a tous mal fait pas de
leçon à recevoir de vaches des
entreprises
chiffrées financé avec un certain nombre
de mesures à prendre notamment sur
l'immigration la réduction de la
contribution de la france à l'union
européenne
ils sont là d'où sortait de l'euro non
non non vous voyez comment vous
caricaturez mais je déjà la culture
parce que j'ai pas mal giner ce que j'ai
parlé de la sortie de l'union européenne
est-ce que j'ai parlé deux ans de
l'union européenne pas du tout je dis
simplement rester là la contribution des
syndicats de copropriété je dis
simplement
je dis simplement pas dire la
contribution de la france mais bien sûr
que nous on ne peut bien sûr que c'est
bon de toute façon je sur les règles
européennes je vois pas vraiment moi
j'aime venir ici
si bruno si le monsieur le député
sortant monsieur je gagnais de ne pas
réaliser j'aimerais quand même revenir
sur un point parce que moi il ya un
point qui m'a énormément choqué ces cinq
dernières années puisqu'on parle du
pouvoir d'achat et que j'ai la chance
pour la première fois d'être face à
monsieur 1000 yens ces deux médias c'est
de lui dire que
j'ai été particulièrement choquée par le
zèle dont il a fait preuve sur les
plateaux de télévision pendant quasiment
une année tous les samedis à soutenir
une répression féroce contre des
citoyens qui justement était pris à la
gorge par le problème du pouvoir d'achat
je parlais gilet jaune bien sûr je
trouve que c'est absolument
indigne de la part d'un député tout ce
qu'il a pu dire pendant cette crise la
cité - oui enfin on pourra que chacun de
trouver chacun pourra retrouver cela
voulait dire que cette politique brutale
soutenu avec zèle par monsieur 1000 yens
a été effectivement indigne indécent tu
échoues la destruction de l'arc de
triomphe est d'aider ses soeurs non mais
là vous confondez vous confondez les
black blocks auquel vous ne vous
attaquez jamais et vous avec laisser les
honnêtes citoyens qui manifestaient et
que eux et que c'est un menteur duras
mais que ceux ci l'on prenne un peu aux
policiers où les photos comment non
c'est un peu assez rares comme le
national contre les black blocks mais la
majorité présidentielle ce que ces
jeunes lançaient le sang s'est jamais
pris naissance ne s'en est jamais venu
au black bloc mais aux honnêtes citoyens
or blanc que je tiens à trianon je tiens
ce que je tiens à dire que finalement
c'est cohérent puisqu'il mène une
politique brutale et méprisante qu'ils
sont dans la déconstruction de la france
et donc il est tout à fait logique dans
leur logique à eux de déconstruire les
valeurs qui sont les valeurs de la
france et notamment celles qui sont
inscrites dans notre devise la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité est loin de voir
des choses non pas du tout parce que
l'égalité et la fraternité a été
détruite à l'occasion de la crise des
gilet jaune liberté des plates je vous
dis l'égalité la fraternité la liberté
des manifestations qui se dit qu'est le
déroulent tous les samedis vous ne
m'écoutez par monsieur 1000 yens vous ne
m'écoutez cas vous mets principal par
les google et par la légalité de fada je
vais pas démérité de maternité l'obsède
en liberté à l'occasion mais si vous ne
coupez pas à chaque fois j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes assez fébrile
ou suivi les pas du tout alors
laissez-moi terminé à daisy voilà je
vous parle d'égalité de fraternité au
moins de la crise des gilet jaune et je
vous parle de liberté au moment de la
crise sanitaire vous avez réussi à
déconstruire ces trois valeurs qui sont
les valeurs cardinales de notre pays et
en cela vous êtes des déconstructeurs
des liquidateurs et même des
destructeurs de larmes de notre pays et
c'est contre cela que nous essayons de
lutter c'est une attaque forte vous
pouvez vous voulez d'abord monsieur
morin était incapable de citer la
moindre de mes paroles sur les plateaux
télé bougez toujours condamnés toujours
qu'on a mais quand il y avait des
violences policières prouver j'ai
toujours dit que si un policier était
accusé de violence et que c'était avéré
il de jeunes à peine par les policiers
jade et j'atteins mes vers le mental du
coup c'est vous qui me couper de devait
être un peu faible
sa première chose deuxième show j'ai
condamné les violences
de certains
manifestants et il n'y avait pas que des
black blocks excusez moi n'y a pas eu
que les black blocs ont été violents
contre 1 lorsque voulait faire croire
n'avait pas d'un côté les black blocs de
l'autre côté de gentils manifestants
pour l'essentiel ça c'est évidemment
produit comme ça d'ailleurs s'il en fait
j'ai de référence et il n'y avait pas
que le policier ils savent très bien qui
était ce une effrayante et les violences
d'accord première chose deuxième chose
moi je sais pas j'ai fait des
manifestations géantes ont l'effet des
manifestations d'humanisation était un
encadré et de autorisée quand tous les
samedi nous défilé de manière non
autorisée ou transgressé la loi vous
êtes d'accord avec moi mais vous allez
provoquer non mais attendez cette église
est faussé vous avez provoqué la
première mais si vous avancez crise des
gilet jaune monsieur la vérité c'est que
effectivement derrière le grand débat
peut être que ça dure trop longtemps je
peux vous l'accordé mais derrière le
grand débat est derrière il ya eu 17
milliards d'euros mis sur la table pour
ces gens là donc vous pouvez pas dire
que rien n'a été fait là dessus et puis
vous avez bien attiser le feu quand même
oui monsieur bon vous le savez très bien
vous départ lui devait tenter une
récupération ça n'a pas marché donc vous
avez une solution de solidaires de ceux
qui souffrent donnant vos apéritifs
risques et les dégâts sociaux que vous
provoquez ce manga c'est peut-être à
l'appui ce que ce qui intéresse les gens
c'est ce qui va se passer dans la liste
dans les années qui viennent alors il y
avait un autre thème qui était qui était
important aussi c'est celui de
l'environnement on le voit là y ait une
période de ligne plume de chaleur comme
ozzy c'était est un des phénomènes qui
va se reproduire le très souvent
semble-t-il on sort le réchauffement
climatique est ce que là dessus vous
avez et c'est vrai que c'est je serais
pas là cette circonscription est assez
rural donc vous parliez tout à l'heure
de on apporte l'agriculture et le
défi environnemental
quelques là dessus est ce que vous avez
des propositions très concrètes d'abord
concrètement il a été quand même fait
beaucoup de choses pendant ce
quinquennat même si les gens le disent
pas vous prendrez quelques exemples la
fin du plastique unique s'est quant à
elle voté la loi sur le recyclage qui
commence à bien fonctionner contre le
gaspillage et pour l'économie circulaire
a bien fonctionné je vais revenir un
point parce que je sais que ça va ça va
mettre ça m a approché je vais revenir à
un petit point sur la convention
citoyenne puisque je suis sûr qu'on va
en parler la convention citoyenne
c'était quelque chose de très bien cali
le remplace le précédent au moment il a
mis en place il a dit je livre sans
filtre les propositions de construire
citoyenne au parlement parce que le
parlement c'est à lui de légiférer
jusque là tout le monde est d'accord on
consulte c'est normal si les situations
de fo se situait nous ferons des
propositions et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
mais bien le parlement doit travailler
dessus et doit amender et retenir et
faire progresser les choses il ya juste
eu un tout petit problème toute la
première partie de la convention
citoyenne s'est très bien passé puisque
c'était la partie on va dire de
formation des citoyens qui n'était pas
forcément au fait de la chose climatique
pour beaucoup d'entre eux puisqu'ils ont
été tirés au sort il y en a qui avaient
une connaissance très partiel jerry au
réchauffement climatique on peut pas
leur en vouloir tout ne s'intéressent
pas forcément à tous les sujets ça a été
merveilleusement bien fait par les
équipes en place la deuxième partie en
revanche et là moi je me suis un petit
peu
posez en faux par rapport à la deuxième
partie sur l'énoncé des propositions les
propositions ont été faites à la base
par la base d'auditions jusque là rien à
dire la transition énergétique et
écologique est très importante pour
notre pays mais pour tout le monde mais
il faut entraîner tout le monde aussi
bien des citoyens que les filières
économiques or sur les auditions qui ont
été faites sur son audition qui ont été
faites 94 auditions ont été faites
auprès des associations
environnementales et des ong
environnementales j'ai pas de souci la
souris et 6% seulement sur le monde
économique ce qui est arrivé on est
arrivé à des choses un petit peu
paradoxal puisque nous on a reçu la
présidente des 150 à flins chez renault
où elle a appris de la bouche du
directeur général de renault que renault
allait arrêter en 2025 les voitures
électriques elle ne le savait pas donc
on a eu un certain nombre de
propositions le présent avaient dit
qu'ils demandaient trois joker il a pris
trop de jokers et dans ses propositions
à j'en profite pour expliquer parce que
ça a été mal perçu l'argent dans cette
proposition arena qui étaient des
propositions purement réglementaire donc
ça on va le donner et puis à nous de
vérifier qu'effectivement la
réglementation va changer il ya des
propositions qui n'ont de sens que dans
un cadre européen et qui sont en train
d'être votée d'ailleurs un groupe et
puis il y avait les propositions qui
dépendaient du parlement dont celle là
on les a travaillés il ya eu ce mois ci
j'en retiens qu'une je sais pas ce que
j'ai beaucoup travaillé dessus ça fait
près de 30 ans avant complète la loi
climat résidence à faisait près de
trente ans qu'on essaie de rénover enfin
les bâtiments et qu'on les rende
thermiquement acceptable de tout c'est
pas souvent là énergétiques qui sont
placés en référé à la première fois pour
la première fois moi ça me paraissait
une aberration et pour la première fois
on a réussi à trouver à mettre un
mécanisme en place qui permet aux gens
qui sont dans des logements fdg
propriétaire logement f et g de pouvoir
enfin rénové
leurs bâtiments sans avoir de restes à
charges à payer parce qu'il ya deux
mécanismes qui existent un par la banque
postale qu'un prêt à taux zéro mais dont
la mensualité de remboursement est
largement inférieur aux gains qu'ils
vont faire en rénovant leurs maisons et
l'autre que vous pouvez faire avec les
droits de mutation au moment où on
vendait ou au moment nos enfants
héritent de vos logements et ont fait
passer tous ses bâtiments là on sait ça
représente aujourd'hui les demandes là
pour 2022 influent en 2001 terme a fait
750 milles depuis qu'on fait ça depuis
qu'on fait de la transition énergétique
et écologique notamment sur les
bâtiments c'est la première fois que ça
arrive d'accord avant nous étions à
échanger si la vieille 4400 euros était
à payer a priori je suis de 4400 euros
là pour répondre au pouvoir d'achat et
c'est une mesure concrète ça c'est une
moi je préfère ces mesures concrètes
manière si on a le temps bien vous me
lancer sur un sujet heureusement parce
que malheureusement déjà on a dépassé
déborder
leur empreinte sur ce sur ce thème de
l'environnement et de la transition
écologique alors pour faire un très bref
résumé de ce qui vient d'être dit je
constate que les propositions qui sont
faites ne sont que des propositions des
propositions sur les conséquences de
de la problématique environnementale
alors qu'en fait il faudrait s'attaquer
aux causes et les causes qu'elles sont
elles les causes c'est le modèle
économique que défend la majorité
présidentielle et bruno billien la
modèle économique ultralibéral qui
effectivement est responsable de la
destruction de notre environnement de
l'aggravation de notre environnement et
ça je constate que monsieur miled nom
parle n'en parle pas il a d'ailleurs il
ne s'est pas opposé au vote du ceta le
traité de libre échange avec le avec le
canada non non non j'ai bien vérifié
d'ailleurs ça a été dit sur les réseaux
sociaux ne fuie c'est bien ce que je dis
vous ne vous êtes pas opposé vous ne
vous et sera opposée j'ai une
explication non mais attendez ces jeux
je termine vous ne vous êtes pas opposé
à sa donc vous soutenez quelque part ce
modèle qui essaient tirez-vous
qu'effectivement les descripteurs wind
enfin si vous étiez contre ce modèle
ultralibéral vous auriez c'est contre
seconde tout à leur âge de voter moi
j'aurais voté contre par exemple
n'ont pas été occultées pas du tout
lorsque lorsque des mesures sont bonnes
on vote favorable recul quand votre
grappin si vous si vous me permettez de
terminer ce que j'avais à dire monsieur
le dédale des sortants donc donc ce
sujet effectivement du modèle économique
est absolument centrale il faut cesser
d'importer des produits de l'autre bout
du monde alors que nous pourrions les
produire ici nous avons vu à l'occasion
de la crise sanitaire qu'effectivement
nous étions dans l'incapacité de
produire un certain nombre de
le produit absolument essentiel hamas
aux tic au niveau des masques etc donc
il faut
réindustrialiser notre pays relocaliser
faire jouer le localisme les circuits
courts donc ça c'est le modèle que nous
nous défendons verte a très longtemps
qu'on dit ça comme nous avons été les
premiers à le dire nous avons été les
premiers à le dire et c'est le modèle
que nous défendons et c'est pas le
modèle de l'autorité présidentielle et
je voudrais aborder un autre sujet sur
le sujet de l'environnement puisque on
ne le sait pas assez mais on pense que
la région ile de france n'est pas
sujette à l'implantation d'éoliennes
mais c'est faux il y en a dans le sud du
département et si l'on regarde le schéma
régional éolien eh bien eh bien eh bien
eh non content vous êtes contre les
éoliennes si l'on regarde le sujet le
schéma régional éolien on constate que
dans la 9e circonscription il y à toute
une zone qui pourraient être
susceptibles d'accueillir des éoliennes
à terme et effectivement nous le
rassemblement national et moi en
particulier puisque je suis très attaché
à l'environnement vous parliez tout à
l'heure de vos expériences à l'étranger
j'ai beaucoup voyagé à l'étranger dans
des dents des voyages un peu initiatique
très proche de la nature si vous voulez
donc la nature pour moi c'est quelque
chose d'important s'il y avait des
projets d'implantation dans la 9e
circonscription ce qui pourrait être le
cas je m'y opposerai effectivement de
manière tout à fait féroce en
plus de cette façon générale que le
nucléaire qui peut qui peut nous
permettre d'affronter
je pense que dans le dans le mix
énergétique et les respectivement il y a
il y a d'abord ce qu'il faut partir du
principe qu'il n'y a pas d'énergie
propre ça n'existe pas il ya des erreurs
des énergies plus propres idées à
d'autres pour nous il n'y a pas
d'énergie propre et parmi les énergies
les plus propres effectivement le
nucléaire l'hydroélectrique sont deux
énergie essentielle il y en a d'autres
que nous avons développée dans le projet
présidentiel de marine le pen notamment
l'hydrogène mais en aucun cas le
photovoltaïque et l'éolien est une
énergie propre c'est l'éolien est
produit avec des éléments qui sont non
recyclables
artificialisés la terre il détruit la
faune il détruit le tourisme aux
alentours de l'implantation de ces
éoliennes il d il dévalorise les biens
et surtout c'est une énergie
intermittente c'est à dire que quand
elle ne produit pas d'électricité on est
obligé de la compense ça a été le cas en
allemagne par exemple avec la
réouverture des usines à gaz qui du coup
détruisent encore plus l'environnement
donc l'éolien et le photovoltaïque sont
de fausses bonnes idées et je ne m'y
opposerais dans la 9e circonscription de
toutes mes forces vous êtes à égalité de
temps un peu frais je peux juste juste
un peu mais ça devrait comprendre un peu
c'est revoir ta carte blanche et oui
c'est grave c'est factuellement faux
seins sur le sur le recyclage désole m
les klaxons ans et clara l'éolienne
aujourd'hui les nouvelles qui sortent
elles sombrent cyclable à 93% quant au
socle celui qui a mis l'éolienne est
tenu de l'enlever et le parti en contre
nous démantèlerons effectivement les
eaux leur façade va nous coûter 2
milliards 5 et c'est un choix monsieur
n'est valide entre la politique c'est un
vilain et 20000 emplois ça vous pose pas
de problème des emplois vous qui
défendez les emplois pourront être
développés dans le vin versé plus de
rondelles j'aimerais vingt mille agents
retrouvent un mille là bas il ya aucun
problème sur le sujet
alors excusé a fait baisser le chômage
n'avait pas fait baisser le chômage si
on regarde un peu plus tard en temps
fort les yeux regarde chez blanc théorie
mesure
parce que les mêmes mesures depuis
depuis toujours il répondre à ça donc
c'est dire si l'on regarde les chiffres
du chômage tout comme toutes catégories
confondues il n'y a absolument pas de
baisse et surtout il y à une
numérisation une précarisation des
emplois qui sont créés aussi bien chez
les salariés que dans les micro
entreprises et ce n'est pas une solution
je pense descente pour les travailleurs
et les jeunes chefs d'entreprise que de
leur proposer cette précarisation de la
société mais les autres demandes des
salariés vous savez que sur les trois
millions d'emplois proposés là pour
l'année 2022 70% sont des cdd ou cdd cdi
donc on est loin de la précarisation
voilà avec il dit non c'est de ces
entrepreneurs en passant aux cartes
blanches si vous êtes d'accord
qui commence lundi dans ces froids que
je veux jouer poli mais bon non mais moi
ma carte blanche va concerner plus tôt
la 9e circonscription
je voudrais m'adresser aux concitoyens
la deuxième section circonscription leur
expliquer pourquoi
j'ai tout le respect que j'ai pour
monsieur morin élire un député et rennes
qui plus est dans l'opposition
à emmanuel macron sur la 9e
circonscription leur servir à rien on a
commencé à mettre en place des choses
sur la circonscription a commencé à
travailler notamment avec l'usiné
renault de flins qui va libérer des
terrains pour pouvoir installer des
filières puisqu'on parlait de transition
écologique transition énergétique
défilent à deir de retrofit notamment
pour les poids lourds parce que ça va
être un vrai sujet parce que là il ya du
retard donc pour pouvoir commencer à
créer ces filières là et on commence à
travailler sur cette vallée de seine
dont flins mais pas que flins dont flins
pour essayer de refaire ce qui existait
dans les années 70 c'était la vallée de
l'automobile mais là on va en enfer la
vallée de l'automobile de demain on a
commencé à faire en sorte que la
désertification médicale
elle n'a pas disparu mais elles soient
moins importantes la preuve on a créé
partout en france pratiquement 2000
maisons
de santé de minéraux santé et puis
surtout on a obtenu quelque chose je
n'ai pas obtenu tout seul moi je veux
être complètement honnête j'ai obtenu
avec le maire de houdan gens
n'arrêtaient tard on a réussi à faire
classer l'hôpital de houdan en hôpital
de proximité qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire plus de subventions ça veut
dire un centre de santé qui ne fermera
pas c'était la grande crainte les
habitants de houdon parce qu'il ya plus
généraliste et ça veut dire aussi un
mammographe 9 et puis le de la dernière
chose qu'on essaie d'obtenir c'est un
centre d'urgence de des urgences je
dirais de la bobologie pressé de
désengorger dreux et rambouillet on a
commencé à travailler avec les
agriculteurs de 10 secondes avec les
agriculteurs et là notamment une font
confiance puisqu'il se trouve que me de
l'agriculture qui va prendre les pins de
julian normandie est un ami très cher
depuis longtemps on a déjà commencé à
travailler pour la loire la culture qui
vient et la transition énergétique je
fais déjà partie des équipes die
espagnol une hache et qui vient de voir
où dans ce soir d'ailleurs à partir de
18h30 donc voilà si vous ne lisez pas
sur une neuvième circonscription tout ce
qu'on est en train de mettre en place ne
sera pas parce que monsieur morel n'aura
aucun levier car aucun accès
monsieur morin normaux sains et bien
écoutez je pense que ce second tour de
l'élection législative dans la 9e
circonscription est une opportunité
l'opportunité pour la 9e circonscription
une opportunité pour les électeurs de
cette circonscription pour les habitants
car ils ont l'opportunité
pour la première fois dans les yvelines
de faire barrage à ce que je donnais
tout à l'heure l'extrême centre et cette
politique brutale et méprisante qui a
été mise en oeuvre pendant cinq ans et
qui ne manquera pas d'être mises en
oeuvre pour cinq ans supplémentaires
puisque je les lis tout à l'heure les
annonces ont déjà été faites il y aura
des réformes brutales et profonde donc
j'appelle les électeurs de gauche à
voter pour moi car sans cela ils auront
le saccage de notre système social et la
réforme des retraites de la retraite à
65 ans j'appelle les électeurs de droite
a voté pour moi car un jeu serait le
défenseur de l'identité et de la
sécurité nous n'avons pas parlé ce soir
des événements honteux du stade de
france mais je crois que c'est l'exemple
de la faillite en matière de sécurité de
la majorité présidentielle est une honte
pour la france au niveau international
donc j'appelle les électeurs de droite a
voté pour moi pour cela et j'appelle
également les électeurs qui ont voté
pour bruno myle yens au premier tour à
réviser leurs leur vote car je pense
qu'avec la politique que monsieur mac
romaine ils finiront par en être
victimes d'une manière ou d'une autre
sur ce sur un certain nombre de sujets
qui les touchent de manière de manière
proche comme la sécurité le pouvoir
d'achat etc et j'appelle enfin les
abstentionnistes également à se
mobiliser car ils ont l'opportunité
d'écarter un député de la majorité et
d'élire un alternative en en ma
candidature une alternative crédible
sérieuse patriotes à
alala la majorité présidentielle qui a
démontré pendant cinq ans son incapacité
à faire avancer le pays il vous reste
encore quelques secondes c'est vouloir
ou alors vous les abandonnez vous voilà
le type d'usagé peut-être question donc
en gros des milliers d oui d'accord vous
si vous élisez laurent morin il me faut
il va être un opposant il varie va
pouvoir rien faire d'autre cette
circonscription mais l'objectif
l'objectif est effectivement de limiter
la casse et de ne pas donner les pleins
pouvoirs emmanuel macron donc il s'agit
de constituer un groupe puissant à
l'assemblée nationale le député
patriotes du rassemblement national qui
permettront d'une part de faire des
propositions de bon sens sur tous les
sujets mais d'autre part de s'opposer
aux mesures qui ne manqueront pas d'être
brutal je les dis et méprisante comme
nous l'avons vécu pendant cinq ans donc
il est très important je pense que
véritablement la 9e circonscription les
électeurs de cette circonscription ont
l'opportunité de marquer le coup dans le
département des yvelines en votant pour
une candidature patriotes et ben on aura
la réponse dimanche dimensions proches
soit débout je sois un peu alors vous
avez parlé de 19 minutes 20 vous n'avez
pas dix neuf études disent ça vous voir
très bien avec cette délicieuse dont
parle un peu plus
merci en tout cas à tous les deux et
puis maintenant bonne c'est donc aux
électeurs de la 2e circonscription de se
prononcer ça sera dimanche prochain
merci merci
[Musique]